[Applaudissements]
on s'amuse à faire un petit zapping de
plein d'émissions télé sauf qu'on a
redoublé les émissions aux îles et ford
a toujours des nouveautés ne s'arrêtent
jamais bon chien c'est la course aux
talents la course à la réussite mais on
essaie de vous surprendre j'aimerais pas
qu'on tombe dans un train train et cars
n'est qu'en profitent donc la raison un
peu de piment aux couples peuvent alors
il va doubler vas-y vas-y leurs stats en
bouillon c'est parti
pisa ping de diverses émissions télé et
variés petit pêle-mêle pour pourri très
pourri c'est un billet dit ma y avait
plein de reina elles connaissent pas l
accepter tout 7 euros ce budget dubaï a
fait la bise ou se contente du quota est
nette mais en moselle
ouais doivent les mains beaucoup merci
je sais c'est cool
il a lu mon cul ça fait bien
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans des
chiffres et des lettres des partis pour
se faire chier pendant une heure comme
chaque soir vous avez l'habitude on va
se faire chier avec bertrand renard et
ariane qui sont à l'ouest ça fait 35 ans
qu'on s'emmerde ça va pas changer
aujourd'hui bon deux candidats semblent
du s'emmerder avec nous pour dire à tout
le monde que j'ai eu mon bac d'accord si
j'ai pas eu mon bac j'ai failli aux
magpies officiers j'ai eu mon bac je les
bats mon mari tout cela et pourquoi a
t'il thomas schütte mais non j'ai pas
mon bac arrête de dire aujourd'hui mon
bac dégueulasse bienvenue dans le mag
on commence bien sûr par le sujet
brûlant la loi m conneries vous en
pensez quoi de son poids lourd s'est pas
là dessus le décret 67 est une
aberration c'est une année là attention
attention la dcri 67 et pas ratifié par
le sénat donc pas conforme à la
constitution vous le savez sa percée
dans le code civil venant à peut-être
que vous reposer votre côté ville
attention un robinson la cie négateurs
universel il prend pas au prorata de ses
émoluments au moins je m'en fous quelle
belle journée ensoleillée en corner ça
bouge ça me donne envie d'entendre une
de ces bonnes blagues
ah oui je peux te raconter la plaque des
trois people in en babouches joue sur
des manières on peut la raconter mais en
anglais oh my mistakes doha à 10 6 3
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]